يمكنك أن ترى الأعلام مضاءة هناك
أم أنك تعلم أنها مؤثرة جدًا
بطريقة لن يحدق فيها جو بايدن
في هاوية ديفيد بالمعنى
الحرفي والمجازي ، نعم الأعلام الأمريكية
بدلاً من الناس هناك ، لكنها
مجرد لحظة و  لا بد لي من أن
أصدق اللحظة التي فكر فيها جو بايدن
على
مدار 36 عامًا زائدًا
عن ترشحه للرئاسة
وإيقافه ، نعم
أه ننسى أن هذه هي محاولته الثالثة هذه
كانت محاولته الثالثة للرئاسة
أه مسيرته المهنية التي استمرت 50 عامًا  في الأساس
أه في واشنطن وبالطبع
لا يوجد شيء بخصوص
هذه
الانتخابات في 2020 لا شيء عن هذا
الانتقال ولا شيء عن
الافتتاح
غدًا كما كان يتصوره جو بايدن
ولكن هذه
هي اللحظة أه التي
يُطلب منه الآن الاجتماع
بالبلد وإه ما تسمعه
عن كيف أنه نوعًا ما يعد
لباس الافتتاح
ما تراه ينظر إلى كل
تلك الرمزية الأمريكية
مع تلك الأعلام أه ستكون أه
سيكون أسلوبه في هذه اللحظة
هو مناشدة
الدولة
للتوحيد لحل بعض أكبر التحديات التي
واجهتها البلاد على الإطلاق